my
best relationships with founders
are the one are those that they'd call
me and say hey this and this is
happening
could you help me relay this to the
investors how would you react to this um
this is what's going on i need some
advice and and
you know remembering that we're on the
same side
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders we're
talking to another
different story of venture capital meet
lyron azreland managing partner of
marone capital
lauren is the general partner at maron
capital and she has over 10 years of
experience in the venture capital
private equity and tech industries
she also manages the young venture
capital forum in israel a professional
organization connecting over 250 young
partners principals and associates from
all vc firms in israel
prior to joining their own capital
levrone was a principal at bloomberg
capital and led cyber sas marketing tech
and infrastructure i.t deals
prior to that she was a strategy and m a
consultant at bain capital and pwc's pe
group in new york where she led
commercial and operational due diligence
projects for the largest private equity
firms in the u.s
before moving to the us leron was a
technical applications engineer at
agilent technologies where she worked
with blue chip clients in europe asia
and the us
leron holds an mba from mit sloan and
msc in computer science from mit and a
bsc in math and physics from the hebrew
university of jerusalem at 25 she was
the youngest student ever to graduate
mit's dual mba and msc degree program
she started her bachelor's degree at
talpiyot the elite israeli defense
forces program and completed it while
serving full time as a technology
analyst and researcher at the israel
intelligence unit 8200
[Music]
i think that
you you really do embody you know how i
think of you know the right investors
right you know the persona that i would
say okay this is a person that you know
that has gone through some really
meaningful things in their life whether
it be the talpiot program for example
one of the most incredible things that a
person can do you know with intellectual
rigor not to mention then transitioning
to to doing your mba and your masters at
mit and and now kaufman fellow for the
last four years and and also
transitioning within the vc space you
know growing
throughout different positions which
we'll share in a minute but but growing
to be more in a decision-maker seat
deploying capital into some some amazing
companies with a very very impressive
portfolio under the fund uh that that
you're leading now marone capital and so
a lot of a lot of you know decisions to
unpack here that i'd like to pick your
brain about
uh but we'll i'll start off asking you
to share with me just a little bit about
your journey and and if you look back
what are some of the big milestones that
you recall that
that made you who you are today
sure and i i guess before diving into
the details allow me to kind of divide
my story into two parts because i
honestly only think that
the latter part is um significant or or
of significant interest and and i'll say
this uh and i'll say why
so calpia
mit
[Music]
agilent technologies you know the path
that i took probably up until i was 28
or so
uh has a lot to do with getting accepted
to places
and and honestly um yeah i'm pretty good
at getting accepted to places it's about
storytelling it's about positioning it's
about marketing it it's about kind of
understanding where you're getting what
they're looking for
what you have and bridging them
and and that that's great that's a great
skill but it's not very
operational
so
it's briefly uh like you mentioned i uh
i got accepted to to tell people when i
was 17 i did most of my undergrad there
left the unit to join one of the
um top units at 8200 that was also uh
getting let's say you start getting job
interviews at the army which is kind of
surreal but that was also uh kind of a
getting accepted move
after i uh both graduated and finished
the army i went to agilent technologies
then a dual degree at mit
bain and company pwc and then i came
back to israel for to join bloomberg
capital so
um yeah like i i think
it really helps to be in a lot of these
top places but
if you ask me what i'm the most proud of
it's absolutely uh founding and building
milan capital because
this has nothing to do with
getting the approval of some uh someone
standing at the door um you know some uh
selector saying you get in
you don't this only has to do with
result and how much money i'm bringing
my investors of course you need to sell
your investors so you know being really
good at positioning and
selling or fitting understanding what
the pattern is and drawing the line
between who you are and
what that is
um so that helps but unless you bring
money over money this is all meaningless
like you get measured
at the result and and i think and so if
you ask me even though milan capital um
well it's starting to be a brand now but
it's hardly a uh sequoia at this point
it's it's the part in my resume that i'm
most proud of
it felt fantastic and i have no doubt it
will be a sequoia in no time but but but
of course i don't undermine
knowing this is part of the experience
myself of working within you know the
unit and and going to some of these
colleges you know at the end yes it's
about getting in but but once you're in
it's incredibly intensive i mean i mean
the amount of sleepless nights is is
almost unbearable and the the stress and
the pressure and the the inten the
intensity and and i do think that it
says a lot
about a person who goes through their
stages and consistently performs at the
highest degree when they're called up to
the to the moment right i mean it's not
just about you know getting in with a
great story from my team but then you're
actually going and doing a joint degree
an mba and a master's i mean it's it
doesn't go it doesn't go easily but
transitioning a little bit to this idea
of of investor so take me you know
you're
very technological you're very you're
you are hands-on
and you finish you know
your path within the army and within the
academia and and within the world but
then you transitioned to bloomberg
capital as an investor was this so sort
of the plan to then at the end become an
investor and create your own fund was
this the big plan for you
uh
no
so um i think i
always kind of wanted to be a cto like a
technology leader and a founder
yeah great question because uh
i i think one of the shocks that i that
i got when i started capital
is um so i was moving from being a
principal at bloomberg capital a fund
that had an existing brand uh
existing deal flow portfolio exits track
record um and i wasn't the decision
maker so so honestly when deals fell
through when founders decided not to go
with us i wasn't even always the one
receiving the news so i wasn't even
um all that much aware to the level an
investor needs to to sell himself and
and how much
it's about
being um
wanted being valuable by the right
founders and right uh
uh people
and
not necessarily about making the right
choice so
um so yeah that was quite a shock
especially you know
quite an expensive lesson to learn when
you're starting as a as an investor and
as a
decision maker in your own brand but but
i think
uh both my partner and i learned learned
that pretty fast
um
and and can you can you speak a little
bit more about this because today there
is you know it's a founder's world
um
and this idea of you know the investors
selling themselves and and bringing
value to the partnership table because
if it's there if these are you know the
right founders working on a good product
i mean they're going to have
a bunch of options in today's world
right yeah and so you're how how so so i
i understand the term you know the way
you have to sell yourself but
how does it actually go in the tangible
world let's say you know you meet a
founder that you really want to invest
in and obviously you have others that
want to invest in them too what what
happens now so hopefully that doesn't
happen hopefully i meet
a
very strong developer
considering to become a founder
considering starting his own company and
i
meet with him every with him her every
three every few weeks we ideate together
i connect them to other
founders and
hopefully before they even realize they
become fundable i realize that so so our
best fields are one that we um
we help grow
and that's for two reasons one is
because these are the founders that
understand our value the most they've
had
the most chance to to see what we bring
to the table how we help and how we
respond to
say imperfect plans imperfect
situation so so they kind of have a
chance to test drive us as investors
um and the second thing is that i
absolutely hate the 24-hour term sheet
so
if and and you know i've seen some fun
pride themselves of it like we can we
can give uh founder term sheets in 24
hours and and okay that's a shotgun
marriage so
you're forcing different right
yes it's a it's a loping yeah that
really that really is what it is
regardless you know for good and for bad
you're eloping you know and i have to
say i agree it drives me
crazy thinking okay you know in in an
ideal world nobody would give a term
should within 24 hours nobody would give
a term sheet within a week there's no
way that you've exhausted
the due diligence process that you need
to do in order to deploy you know
potentially millions of dollars so if
the market is the force that's driving
behind this intensity i just love your
model of going back and saying wait
we're playing a different game we
actually understand that the real due
diligence here is not just on the
founders and the problem but it's also
on our relationship what happens when we
do meet every two weeks do we enjoy
these meetings do we dread these
meetings and then we say okay wait we
actually want to continue this
partnership and now the investment is
not just you know it's not just the
money we've already invested our time
the money is just accompanying the fact
that we are solidifying this engagement
through sort of a marriage right exactly
that and and honestly with the 24 48
take 72 hour term sheet investors have
no idea how the people they invest in
respond to feedback because there wasn't
any feedback right there was a one-sided
conversation and we noticed because they
mostly came to us
with a pretty bad idea or an idea that
wasn't fundable at that moment
but we saw something in the team in the
potential and and that
that's more important and and you know
the the funny thing is the industry is
so crazy right now that sometimes while
we do this process before we're willing
to to say okay they've hit something
other funds
swoop in and and take the deal and and
that's totally fine
because i mean you know we do it in our
own time we
work with
enough and when i say enough it's still
a handful but but we're we're like uh
diamond pickers we're not we're uh spear
uh hunters not no we're not fishing with
nets
so um
i like that yeah so
so the the conversion rate from from
meeting of founders is high enough
meaning with the founder regularly is
high enough that it's scalable for us
because we only need
three max four deals per partner per
year
um so so yeah so that that's something
we really really like doing and those
were our best deals hopefully we're uh
we're about to do do another deal like
this um uh pretty soon
so um yeah and and i think in a lot of
ways that's our differentiator we do
sometimes do
uh deals that have the the normal
process and and i think those
are a little bit more deals where we
feel we see something that the others
don't we feel like there's
there might be some reason to not do the
deal but we feel like we stay past it
and and those deals we love as well
[Music]
fantastic i mean and it's i think that
it's
so interesting from a founder's
perspective um and and i haven't been
there myself yet so so it's hard for me
to gauge you know the emotional state
and the mental state but i'm thinking
you know you're going on this 10-year
journey potentially
and and you you want to understand who
your investor is as well there's no way
you you've also done your due diligence
and i understand the market play and you
know yeah you you have you know you have
momentum and you want to close but you
know i'm always i'm always thinking you
know once when i'm in the process from
an investor's side and the founder tells
me sorry we've just signed the term
sheet and i'm like wait but you know you
didn't you want to spend at least two
more days talking to the different
parties engaging what's happening and
and how much would you lose in those two
days because you're you're married now
so so it's a
anyways uh that's my own little event
but lauren if you're looking at now
marone uh capital financial as a you
know investment body but in the in the
tech sector what is sort of a thesis
what really are you looking for with
maron capital um so that comes back more
closely to the last question than you
think because
um
since we do hunt with a sphere
it's
more like the team
is a lot more important and the deals
that we identify
as deals tend to be more important than
pieces driven or betting on the right
market so we do have market that we
perceive as strong in markets that we
perceive as weak
but we put this into play when we have
those discussions with the founders so
our thesis is
strong resilient founders
operating in
growing markets with good dynamic and
and honestly we're open to having a
founder convince us
that
a market that we see it difficult or not
great um is actually has actually has
enough merit to to warrant in his time
spent there and and this is this is
actually the deal we're looking at right
now
and if you're looking at
more broadly sort of the way that you
like to engage and interact wednesday
once the deal is made
right so your involvement with the
founders and and right prior to the call
you mentioned a few instances of how you
are actively engaging with the founders
not just on the on a coaching level but
also on a business level so what is sort
of your preferred engagement style with
the companies that you invest in um so
i think in this
structure we're the trusted party
so
my
best relationships with founders
are the one
are those that they'd call me and say
hey this and this is happening
could you help me relay this to the
investors how would you react to this um
this is what's going on i need some
advice and
you know remembering that we're on the
same side and not stressing and
realizing that
most businesses
fail because of um
you know not notwithstanding the heat
rather than maybe not making the most
accurate decision and and having um
having us care for the the founder uh
it's not really peace of mind but it's
like continuous resiliency because it's
a marathon you need you need to stay
strong
uh it's something that brings tremendous
value and this is what we strive to
bring
i love it and
i i really wanna
thank you for for for opening up with me
you know a few interesting questions
here i think that we you know we got a
little philosophical there for a bit but
it's but but those are the important
questions in the end
and um you know i i entered the vc world
not from a not from a financial
perspective and i constantly think about
this dynamic of at the end what are we
trying to do we're trying to build great
companies and we have different sides
and it sounds like you coming in from
the very hands on side as in sort of as
as an operator you know
but but with operator mentality not
necessarily the you know a former ceo
but an operator mentality and you very
much see yourself
as as a as a you know married partner to
the entrepreneurs which which i think is
the healthy way um of looking at these
investments which is and it's
interesting to see what's happening with
the markets today and i and obviously we
have also a few co-investments together
and and i keep hearing just amazing
things and and they really thank you for
your time and continue you know making
great investments into great companies
and and stay safe and stay healthy thank
you
[Music]